what do we see here so my first
impression is that this page looks kind
of messy and if you look into this
probably the main reason is that this
page uses all kinds of different font
sizes and this is really a problem that
you see quite often so let's look here
of course thetion title 28 here this
Title 24 red curve depreciation 18 this
one 20 this 11 18 18 it's really all
over the place and I believe this really
significantly adds to this unclean to
this weird unorganized look so the key
rule that you always want to follow when
doing these types of presentations that
the body of your slide so everything
except for the title and maybe some
footnotes should be the same font size